mais d'abord donc l'horreur dans cette
petite ville du val d au texas 19
enfants deux enseignants a battu dans
leur école et l'amérique en deuil se
repose la question du contrôle des armes
gaspard flamand il est midi heure locale
au texas quand un adolescent de 18 ans
ouvre le feu dans cette école le bilan
humain est lourd dix neuf élèves d'une
dizaine d'années et deux professeurs
perdre la vie dans cette fusillade
l'assaillant meurt dans la tacc tué par
la police
les mobiles de la tuerie restent pour
l'instant inconnues le président
américain a tout de suite réagi et
appelle à se confronter au lobby des
armes je suis écoeuré fatigué nous
devons agir et ne me dites pas que nous
ne pouvons pas avoir d'impact sur ce
carnage j'ai passé ma carrière de
sénateur et de vice-président à
travailler pour faire passer des lois de
bon sens sur les armes à feu
nous ne pouvons pas empêcher et
n'empêcheront pas chaque tragédie de se
produire mais nous savons que ces lois
fonctionnent et ont un impact positif
comme après chaque nouvelle fusillade
sur le sol américain
c'est le débat sur le second amendement
qui revient celui qui autorise la
détention d'armes par tout citoyen au
sénat juste après l attaque cette élue
démocrate livre un réquisitoire contre
la législation du pays
ce n'est pas inévitable ces enfants
n'ont pas été malchanceux cela n'arrive
que dans ce pays et nulle part ailleurs
nulle part ailleurs les enfants vont à
l'école en pensant qu'il pourrait être
abattus ce jour là chatel du côté des
républicains son de cloche radicalement
différent le parti est très attaché au
port d'armes
nous savons de par les expériences
passées que le moyen le plus efficace
pour assurer la sécurité des enfants est
d'armes et la police dans les écoles
vous voyez le parti démocrate dire dans
les médias que la solution immédiate et
d'essayer de restreindre le droit
constitutionnel mais ça ne fonctionne
pas sur l'année 2021 vingt mille
personnes sont mortes par arme à feu aux
états unis
c'est un interminable cauchemar
américain dont on va débattre tout de
suite dans ce sens public avec mes
invités sabrina vente à celle
bonjourbonjour êtes journaliste franco
américaine réalisée documentaire les
armes de la colère qui est disponible
sur mick hannah j'accueille également
jean-claude beaujour bonson soit vous
êtes avocat spécialisé états unis
françois durpaire bonsoy historien
spécialiste également des états unis et
matthieu croissandeau éditorialiste
politique bonsoir on soit mathieu c'est
cette nouvelle tuerie de masse sabrina
avant tout à celles qui frappent des
enfants c'est ce qui évidemment nous
nous nous rend particulièrement voilà ça
nous émeut particulièrement est ce
qu'elle peut avoir un peu plus d'impact
dans l'opinion américaine c'est une
question qui va être récurrente dans ce
débat on a tellement cette impression
que ça n'en finit pas que ça recommence
je ne sais pas je ne crois pas en fait
parce que il ya une blague et j'ai eu la
tuerie de sandy hook ces quelques années
et l'amérique était en émoi encore une
fois le président obama a pleuré pareil
un petit peu que byden on voit les mêmes
images et pourtant ça se recommandent à
l'infini il faudrait vraiment des vrais
enfin de loi fédérale très forte qui
soit obéi par tous les états et ça
malheureusement c'est quasi impossible
aux états unis ça se passe au texas
jean-claude beaujour est ce que c'est le
pays le l'état le plus armé au principe
c'est l'état où il y aurait le plus
d'armes d'armes et puis c'est surtout
une culture une culture dans le sud
aujourd'hui on a entendu le sénateur
murphy mais qui tenait lui du nord dans
le sud on reste attaché malgré tout à
cette liberté des armes il ya une vraie
fracture de ce point de vue il ya une
vraie fracture entre les républicains et
démocrates qui amènent des démocrates
sont pour la
le pendu et on voit que je comprends et
je partage l'avis suivant lequel on ne
sait pas comment est-ce qu'on peut
sortir de cette affaire à la froide
raison de sociologie une fois qui a eu
les mois on l'a vu en 2012 obama a
pleuré parce qu'on m'a dit ben laden est
ému mais obama a pleuré en 2012 eh bien
on voit bien que bon ça ça passe et
chacun reprend son son reprend son son
chapitre sur sa poigne kwal ma liberté
parce que ce topic est profondément
enraciné sur qui culturellement s'est
bâtit aussi sur la violence il ya aussi
une explication vous ne pouvez pas
passer de la ségrégation à des
ségrégations sans violence
d'affrontements communautaires entre
guillemets religieux d'un conte
structure l'america quelque chose donc
ça ne veut pas dire qu'on ne peut pas
aller au delà mais on sent bien qu'il ya
les ferments de la violence et donc à
chaque fois ça ça repart donc
sociologiquement difficile politiquement
compliqué parce que vous entendez les
républicains et puis à le lobby des
armes qui est qui nouvelle occasion mais
évidemment parler national rifle
association
mon accent et il n'est pas n'est pas à
la hauteur de ce débat mais vous
m'excuserez françois durpaire comment
réagissent les médias américains depuis
quelques heures depuis que ce drame a
été connue alors les médias américains
ils sont très haut en ce moment ils sont
très dirigé vers les élections mille
terme dont immédiatement est très
rapidement par rapport aux autres
tueries on a immédiatement fait le lien
avec ce qu'il va se passer le 8 novembre
prochain ca les élections et c'est aussi
les démocrates qui ont invité les médias
à le faire puisque immédiatement ils ont
proposé de législation vous vous
rappelez ya la semaine dernière fois il
ya dix jours il ya une autre tuerie
cette fois à buffalo ça a été un peu
moins politisés on a parlé beaucoup du
racisme beaucoup moins du port d'armes
sur la question de buffalo mais en fait
la situation sont assez proches la
différence ils étaient tous les deux ils
avaient tous les de 18 ans la situation
c'est que dans le premier cas il ya eu
des revendications extrêmement précises
raciste pour le coup donc on a parlé
beaucoup du racisme du suprématisme
blanc beaucoup moins du port d'armes en
fait la question était quand même là
même c'est que 77% depuis 1966 jusqu'à
aujourd'hui de ces jeunes qui commettent
des actes des hommes parce qu'il ya très
peu de femmes qui commettent ce type
date eh bien ils obtiennent les armes
légalement alors il ya quand même une
petite musique dans la presse américaine
qui consiste à dire attention c'est pas
que l'histoire se répète c'est que
l'histoire s'aggrave et donc en donnant
des chiffres même si évidemment on est
là face à beaucoup d'émotion elle mais
les chiffres c'est d'abord que
aujourd'hui il ya 400 millions d'armes à
peu près dans la société américaine 331
millions d'américains et donc plus
d'armes que d'américains le citoyen
américain et que ça n'a pas toujours été
le cas qu' on est là face à un rythme
d'achat des armes à feu qui est
considérable et qui a augmenté au cours
des 20 dernières années si on prend même
un peu plus de profondeur historique
pour vous donner un exemple il y avait à
peu près 4 millions d'armes le produites
annuellement début des années 2000
aujourd'hui on est environ de 11 à 12
millions d'armes produites par an ça
veut dire que derrière la nra et à vous
historique et oui que ces voix là que
c'est la constitution que ceux de
l'identitaire je rappelle quand même que
les cowboys sont très armés dans les
westerns on a vu à la télé les westerns
des années 50 ils sont pas vraiment armé
dans la vraie conquête de l'ouest ce
sont des fermiers les cowboys alors
d'abord il y avait peut-être une heure
mais enfin on n'était pas du tout il ya
une sorte de mythologie quand je dis
cela c'est monstrueux arme au poing
c'est un peu une mythologie c'est un peu
alors certes la violence dont parlait
jean claude et les réelles génocide
amérindiens l'esclavagé une vraie
violence dans ce pays en revanche
effectivement le cowboy celui qui a
besoin de son art pour se sortir de
toutes les situations sas à la
mythologie de des far west des années
des années 50 et ça c'est hollywood
c'est pas le far west
par exemple j'avais pas de noirs dans
les far west des années 50 on sait que
j'avais des éleveurs noir pour dire un
exemple entre la réalité historique et
l'arrière paul hegy géographie la
géographie ingrate l'arizona toute une
partie de la californie on se dit mais
type il en voulait physiquement ça ne
veut pas dire qu'ils étaient des
guerriers mais mais mais ils en
voulaient donc on peut comprendre il a
fallu se protège et puis souvenez vous
que même en france je veux dire à une
période se transporter c'était aussi
prendre un dicton qu'on peut imaginer
tout ça mais ils sont nommés le
sentiment qu'on n'arrive pas à se sortir
de cela on utilise la constitution
certains utilisent la constitution oui
pour ne pas progresser de ce projet et
lorsqu'à de l'industrie il ya
évidemment effectivement pour abonder
dans ce que dit jean claude sur les 28
les plus meurtrières de l'histoire des
états unis huit ont eu lieu depuis 2014
donc dire ça a toujours été l'amérique
et violence et tous les noms les années
60 qu'elle est la violence politique etc
il n'y avait pas toutes les semaines une
tuerie dans une école ça n'existait pas
d'ailleurs on voit d'ailleurs cette
cette liste horrible des et des
principales tuerie de columbine en 1999
oui je pourrais tout le monde se
souvient de colombes en 99 c'est bien
parce que c'était une tuerie isolés que
ça tous choqués que c'était une
sidération et que parce que ça faisait
très longtemps que ça n'avait pas eu ces
voix là et que vous nous dire ce qu'on a
retrouvé c'était c'était 66 avant une tu
vas voilà 056 installé depuis sandy hook
parkland et là où va lever donc ça veut
dire que ça reste moins dans la mémoire
collective et peut-être qu'on en fait
même tête - alors que colomb heinz et
c'est bon c'est beaucoup de morts 1 ces
quinze morts et moins deux morts
qu'aujourd'hui je suis sûr qu'il va y
avoir une couverture de presse un peu
moins important vous n'allez pas que
dans quelle chance de réalisateurs qui
est une banalise quand un client
duration à la violence pas de toutes les
tueries qui ont juré semaine louis qui
font très bien voilà qui font très peu
de morts 2 3 morts parce que le pardon
tous les morts par balles chaque rue
chaque jour aux états unis j'ai appris
en préparant les missions qu'en fait il
ya un seuil pour dire tueries de masse
ces quatre morts ah ça oui où est la
villa chiffres effrayants que donne le
washington post aujourd'hui c'est trois
cent mille enfants exposés en tant que
victime ou témoin direct traumatisée
depuis colombani de tueries de masse des
trois cent mille enfants et deuxième ou
troisième cause de mort il y aurait
peut-être même deux émissions en faire
mais c'est pas pour des une deux mais
sur deux phénomènes qui sont pas tout à
fait les mêmes il ya une émission à
faire sur les fusillades de masse c'est
un phénomène c'est à peu près 600 par an
il ya un émission à faire sur les armes
dans la société américaine lah ces
quarante cinq mille morts par an c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose de masse
d'un côté présence d'armes à feu de
l'eau qui fait par exemple que le taux
de suicide est très élevé aux états unis
allez y les réussites de suicide qui
fait que les enfants se blesse ou se
tuent avec les armes à feu qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas si on fait
l'émission fusillade masse on va dire
qu'il ya 19 morts aujourd'hui 19 enfants
si on fait les missions les armes on dit
qu'aujourd'hui à 119 morts tous les
jours aux états unis 119 morts c'est
d'ailleurs ce que vous montrez dans
votre documentaire sabrina van tassel
c'est les armes de la colère que l'on
règle nombre est qu'un conflit de deux
d'automobiles
décembre a compté je vais vous laisser
la raconter je suis dit si ça sent
totalement absurde quoi mais oui
l'histoire du fils de ron davis qui va
dans une station service qui met la
musique un peu trop fort
un automobiliste sort et dit lui dit
baisse la musique il le fait pas il sort
son arme et il tire une dizaine de fois
dans la voiture oui donc c'est un
conflit en automobilistes qui se règlent
par les armes vous avez rencontré les
deux amériques pour le documentaire les
pro armes et programmes et les
pacifistes est ce qu'ils arrivent un
tant soit peu à dialoguer ou alors que
c'est vraiment deux univers qui ne s'est
pas non mais c'est impossible l'amérique
n'a jamais été aussi autant divisé aussi
divisés qu'aujourd'hui de toutes les
façons entre républicains et démocrates
il n'y a aucun dialogue aujourd'hui et
c'est la même chose pour les pro et anti
armes on a d'un côté les pro am qui
pensent que le second amendement est
donc un amendement céleste qui vient de
dieu et donc on ne doit absolument pas y
toucher il est hors de question
de faire ce qu'on appelle et baghran
tchèque c'est-à-dire de voir si les
personnes ont des problèmes
psychiatriques n'ont rien on ne touche à
rien et puis de l'autre côté ceux qui
veulent jouer au contraire une
législation pour arrêter le massacre
alors vous avez les uns et les autres
parler de ce deuxième amendement
alexandre poussin vous pouvez nous nous
rejoindre on va détailler bonsoir
alexandre on va détailler ski le ski le
représente dans la constitution
américaine non bien sûr deuxième
amendement il fait partie des dix
premier amendement de la constitution
américaine ait créé en 1791 et je vais
le site et il prévoit et bien je le cite
une milice bien organisée étant
nécessaire à la sécurité d'un état libre
le droit qu'a le peuple de détenir et de
porter des armes ne sera pas transgressé
alors en effet ce deuxième est en
mouvement et bien il a divisé les
américains dans l'histoire du pays avec
deux lectures d'abord une lecture qui
comprend que et bien le port d'armes est
autorisé dans un cadre collectif c'est
cette référence à la milice bien
organisée alors aujourd'hui on n'est
plus au temps des mythes des milices
mais ça voudrait dire que pour des
forces de sécurité publique ou privée et
bien le port d'armes est autorisée la
seconde lecture c'est que chaque citoyen
a le droit de porter une arme et dans ce
débat en 2008 la cour suprême américaine
a tranché avec le jugement suivant le
deuxième amendement protège le droit
individuel de posséder une arme à feu
sans pour autant servir dans la milice
et d'utiliser cette arme dans la limite
des dispositions prévues par la loi donc
ça veut bien dire que le deuxième
amendement protège ce droit individuel à
porter une arme alors on l'a évoqué
rapidement et c'est intéressant de
détailler les lois les textes sont
différents en fonction des états c'est
ça oui chaque état adopte sa propre
législation sur les armes il y à des
états plus permissif que d'autres sur le
port d'armes est l'état le plus
permissif c'est le texas dans lequel
s'est passée cette fusillade l'an
dernier au texas et bien l'obligation
d'avoir un permis de port d'armes a même
été abolie tout simplement ça veut dire
que quasiment toutes les personnes âgées
de plus de 21 ans dans cet état peuvent
porter une arme en public et au moment
de l'adoption de ce texte est bien le
gouverneur du texas s'est félicité en
disant que son état devait devenir je
seek le sanctuaire du deuxième
amendement nous devons ériger une
barrière qui résistera à n'importe quel
officielle du gouvernement fédéral qui
voudraient nous interdire ce droit de
posséder des armes au texas wallace
assez pour les propos de greg abbott le
gouverneur du texas l'an dernier en
revanche il y à des états ou le port
d'armes est beaucoup plus restreint où
il faut remplir beaucoup de conditions
pour avoir ce permis de port d'armes
comme avoir un casier judiciaire vierge
répondre effectivement à l'eczéma des
examens médicaux c'est le cas de la
californie l'état de new york restreint
également beaucoup les armes et l'état
de new york s'appuie sur une loi de 1913
qui stipule que le port d'armes ne peut
être permis que pour les personnes qui
sont réellement menacées qui ont besoin
de se défendre est actuellement le lobby
des armes est en train de vie lisez
cette loi new yorkaise de 1913 et a
demandé à la cour suprême de la
supprimer la plus haute juridiction
américaine qui va rendre sa décision et
en cas de suppression de cette loi new
yorkaise et bien ça pourrait porter un
grave coup aux pacifistes à ceux qui
veulent restreindre le port des armes
aux états unis merci alexandre pour tous
ces détails jean-claude beaujour est-ce
que ce deuxième amendement il a il a
déjà été menacé ou un tout petit peu
remis en cause par un camp politique ou
alors ça nous est ce que ça n'est jamais
arrivé
je n'ai pas de hilla et et challenger
mais on est c'est tellement un
amendement centrale que personne
sociologiquement personne n'imagine
d'avoir une juridiction qui vont de la
sortie et dans le cas présent on a une
une cour suprême qui est qui et
conservatrice c'est ce qu'on appelle
ceux qui sont poule à une lecture
originale
comme à l'origine de la constitution et
avec avec cette grosse majorité de la de
la cour suprême on imagine mal qu'elle
puisse qu'elle puisse aller au delà de 2
des réformes qui des tentatives de
réformes et il ya un camp qui quand
progressif qui est trop faible parce que
c'est tout le problème de la cour
suprême c'est qu'aujourd'hui il s'est
considérablement je considère politisé
on sent bien que c'est le camp
républicain
en tout cas le conservateur qui
s'exprime quand on regarde les
nominations on est extrêmement sur des
nominations évidemment il ya des
juristes qui sont des gens très bien
mais on sent bien qu'il ya une doctrine
politique derrière lui a pas toujours
été le cas oui ça
c'était pas la même culture aujourd'hui
on sent bien parce qu'à une polarisation
et c'est parce qu'il ya cette
polarisation que ça s'apprend une force
considérable avant il y avait il y avait
il y avait les majorités pouvait sens et
on pouvait espérer des majorités bush
aujourd'hui il ya une telle
contradiction des frictions entre les
deux camps qu'on ne peut pas imaginer
une seconde que le camp conservateur
puisse bouger face au camp progressiste
le deuxième amendement est pas
aujourd'hui le problème c'est qu'en fait
il serait le problème que si les
démocrates voulaient abroger ce deuxième
amendement en fait il est tout à fait
possible d'éviter ce type de fusillades
de masse d'éviter même que 119 personnes
par jour meurent 45000 personnes par an
sans sans retoucher ou deuxième
amendement ce que demandent les
démocrates c'est simplement que le
congrès puisse vérifier les antécédents
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui par exemple
les républicains ont une vision assez
étrange et disent c'est pas un problème
ce qui s'est passé par exemple dans
cette école d'armes à feu c'est un
problème de de mental illness c'est un
problème de problèmes
logistiques
dans le sujet qu'on a dit oui à combien
ils vont même plus loin il inverse la
logique celanese la solution c'est pas
moins d'armes c'est plus d'armes il faut
armer les instituteurs enfin c'est pour
ça que j'ai mon floride par exemple les
enseignants bat en floride depuis le
massacre du lycée de par klein ont sont
autorisés à porter des armes
ils disent en fait s'il ya des tueries
dans les écoles c'est qu'il ya pas de
gentille personne pour arrêter les
méchantes personnes qui ont des armes
mais ça c'est une chose ils disent il
faudrait que toutes les personnes qui
effectivement ont des problèmes
psychologiques puisse être internés dans
des hôpitaux alors cela dit on ne
comprend pas la logique et des
républicains parce que ça veut dire que
vous faudra les interner mais pas donc
comme ils sont pas interné on peut leur
vendre des armes c'est complètement
illogique donc ce que disent les
démocrates c'est que a minima il
faudrait vérifier les antécédents c'est
à dire qu'ils viennent en car en vernis
obligatoire et une vérification
fication le fbi elle prend le temps de
vérifier les antécédents il ya quand
même deux choses qui sont positives
récemment c'est que 1
aujourd'hui cette génération voit bien
parce que j'appelle les louveteaux
solitaires ils ont 18 ans un site sont
des très très jeune d'ailleurs si on
leur interdisait les armes jusqu'à 25
ans il aurait plus ce genre de problème
en tout cas on peut pas leur interdire
donc ou vérifier les antécédents
ce sont des aussi digital natives ce
sont des gens qui passent leur vie sur
les réseaux sociaux comme le tueur de
diers ou comme le tueur de buffalo qui
laisse des traces à tel point qu
ailleurs le tueur de buffalo disait
apparemment le fbi a il me laisse agir
peut-être même qu'il est complice parce
que ils me laissent agir il comprenait
pas pourquoi on l'arrêté pas alors qu'il
avait le dernier avait publié ces deux
armes donc ça veut dire que si on
considère que c'est un problème de
homeland security c'est vraiment un
problème national le fbi a suit les
traces sur les réseaux de tous ces
jeunes qui après tout sont en décrochage
sont harcelés ça existe aussi en europe
ça c'est le premier aspect le deuxième
aspect positif vous avez vu il ya
quelques semaines que l'état fédéral a
dû payer 125 millions de dollars aux
victimes du lycée de parkland un
objectif de lycées de parkland parce
qu'il a estimé que précisément le fbi
n'avait pas fait son travail et qu'il y
avait des signaux précurseurs et que ces
signaux précurseurs n'avait pas été vu
donc ça veut dire que si on fait un
travail ou moins sur les antécédents ne
pas donner des armes qui sont des armes
de guerre les armes semi-automatiques
mais c'est le traduire tous de retrouver
son fiancé 2 c'est d'intéresser en
fonction de la nature des classes
d'armes oui ça avait été fait
c'est le camp d'en face
qu'avait réussi en asie c'est en
94 les fusils d'assaut sont interdits ça
veut dire que c'est possible après 10
ans bien sûr la loi mettant dans l'oubli
ce qui fait que c'est suzy d'assaut
c'est un petit peu d'une image après je
m'arrête complètement là c'est que c'est
comme si on dit aux américains comme si
l'industrie automobile disait pour aller
faire vos courses il faut une formule 1
là ça veut dire que pour aller faire du
sport pour faire de la chasse il faut 1
h 15 ce qui n'a au poids françois donc
le nom techniquement tu as raison parce
qu'effectivement c'est la logique c'est
quand on écoute constitué normalement se
dit faudrait faire à aller dans ce
sens-là sauf qu'en face quelle que soit
la législation qui sont prises ou qui
seront prises elles seront chargées par
le corps républicain et qui dira vous
voyez tel ou tel texte est une atteinte
à la liberté
ça n'est pas une lecture ça n'est pas un
texte qui est conforme à la constitution
et c'est ça le vrai sujet c'est de se
dire que tant qu'on aura des
républicains qui se sentent finalement
il ya peut-être une marge de manoeuvre
qui ont le sentiment qu'ils ont une
porte une tenue une opinion publique qui
est suffisamment importante pour ne pas
les gêner ils ne feront aucun pas ça
n'est que si et les élections peuvent
être l'occasion de challenge et êtes à
paris tu as mais ça voudra dire que du
le camp d'en face fasse exactement ce
que fit la nra c'est d'interroger les
élus c'est d'aller de fer militer les
familles qui sont malheureusement ces
victimes de voiliers a ce qu'il faut
jouer aussi sur ce mobile by contre
l'odm a les dents pour ce documentaire
vous êtes allé au contact des des pro
armes qui vous ont pas d'ailleurs
forcément bien accueilli non peut mettre
des terrains comme ça est perçu comme
une ennemie avec l'air c'est quoi le
premier argument qu'il donne c'est la
liberté la sécurité c'est la libérale à
la liberté ouakam du fric en tchéquie et
la première chose qu'on ne dit pas vous
bienvenue dans un état libre ça fait du
bien d'être des clips comment vous vous
sentez un vous qui venez nains et à
l'aspect y carrément socialistes
communistes enfin voila c'est vraiment
ce à quoi est donc en fait ils sont là
en se disant voilà nous c'est notre
droit c'est notre culture ça fait partie
de nous n'est encore une fois de notre
droit divin on peut pas challenge et
dieu c'est lui qui nous a donné les
armes ce succès nous dire de religion il
ya un autre argument c'est que souvent
les mêmes sont plutôt pro life
sur la question d'avortement ils
défendent la vie à tout prix
compliqué pro-life ils sont aussi pour
la peine de mort ils sont aussi pour les
armes en face et tout ça se mélange un
petit peu mais en tout cas une chose est
sûre ils ne veulent pas qu'on y touche
echap à toute rationalité c'est ce cas
c'est comme ça ça échappe à tous à dire
les gens que j'ai filmé mois
n'avait pas été agressé par forcément
dépenser des sommes folles pour être
dans ces camps d'entraînement mais il
n'aurait été à jamais rien arrivé mais
il était avec des fusils d'assaut avec
des maires 15 et avait carrément des
courses poursuites dans les maisons
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de femmes alors
il ya de plus en plus de femmes qui
s'arme il ya de plus en plus d'afro
américains qui s'arme et des populations
qui ne savait pas avant qui semble
aujourd'hui locaux vides a fait en sorte
que les gens se sont armés en masse tout
d'un coup les gens ont dû rester chez
eux ils ont pris peur issam là par
exemple ça peut paraître incroyable mais
je peux vous dire que les gens vont
s'armer dès demain à la suite
de cette tuerie thématiquement cesser le
reflex dont on parle est plaqué à l'or
il ya eu évidemment beaucoup de
réactions un petit peu partout dans dans
le monde allez je vous propose celle du
pape françois le pape françois le coeur
brisé on écoute
j'ai le coeur brisé par le massacre
commis dans une école élémentaire au
texas
rimini je prie pour les enfants et les
adultes tuer leurs familles il est temps
de dire ça suffit au trafic incontrôlée
des armes
françois durpaire on a entendu tout à
l'heure dans le reportage qui ouvrait ce
débat la réaction de joe biden lui aussi
très émue alors il ya quand même son
histoire personnelle qui qui ressort on
peut être rappelé en quelques mots
pourquoi c'est un c'est un père en deuil
est doublement en deuil et oui déjà lui
c'est comme
c'est un vice président qui avait pris à
bras le corps le problème de santé ou
qui portait vraiment ce projet et il a
pris vraiment comme un échec personnel
ce sont les larmes d'obama mais derrière
il ya déjà les larmes de baden qui
pensais vraiment pouvoir
avoir vendangé les gens changer les
choses parce que il y avait déjà dire
cette fenêtre d'opportunité émotionnelle
qui faisait que précisément y avait
passé deux amériques face à face parce
qu'après tout la lecture constitutionnel
juge les records avec jean-claude elle
est un petit peu désespérante parce que
la cour suprême elle va pas changer de
d'ici demain donc l'interprétation va
être compliqué
en revanche la lecture historique elle
amène un peu plus d'optimisme
1994 c'est après tout il n'ya pas si
longtemps et c'était la loi brady brady
vous savez l'ancien conseiller de reagan
qui avait été blessé lors de l'attentât
contre régal il y avait aussi ce
policier qui avait été blessé et il y
avait un troisième membre du fbi qui
avait été blessé et donc les policiers
sont partis en croisade contre les armes
qui tuent et les policiers ce qui
traversaient les gilet pare balles dans
plutôt des républicains est plutôt des
républicains donc favorable à ce qu'on
légifère bill clinton puis ramasser les
fruits de tout cela et en 1994 il ya eu
ce fameux bras dit bill ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui parmi les enfants morts
il ya des enfants morts démocrate il ya
aussi des enfants morts républicain il
n'y a pas que des démocrates qui perdent
leurs enfants aujourd'hui alors
peut-être l'aider à deux dernières curie
sans doute un c'était un quartier
afro-américains d'un côté mais c'est à
faire des acquisitions
plutôt ans ont lutté au total ces voix
là
c'est mon rôle de formulation des
enfants démocrate des enfants on est
vraiment aux états ni gouvernementale
famille à son propos l'idée d'aller
laver d'azur est ce que ce sont des
mexicains des cubains et qui vote plutôt
républicain plutôt démocrate mais ce
qu'on veut dire c'est que ça c'est pas
une amérique bleu ou une amérique rouge
c'est une amérique qui perd ses enfants
et ses tablettes qui perd ses enfants et
c'est pour ça que je reviens à joe biden
il ya vraiment il a vraiment subi ça
comme un échec personnel parce qu'on a
été à deux doigts après 110 ou de
vraiment faire passer au sénat une loi
importante en matière de vérification
des antécédents s'est passé devant la
chambre a échoué devant senna pour rien
du tout il s'est dit c'est pour ça que
la is il semble qu'ils veuillent prendre
sa revanche il se dit mon combat n'est
pas terminé et puis essayer de combattre
pour les élections biterne je vais
essayer ensuite d'avoir une majorité est
d'aller chercher les républicains et
c'est pour ça que la personne qui est
essentiel c'est pas joe biden c'est
mitch mcconnell et c'est pour ça y est
le rocher la minorité républicaine
c'est lui qui détient la clé de cette
histoire là s'il y a ne serait ce que
dit républicain capable de voter avec
les démocrates
eh bien on vote une loi sur les
antécédents puis juste une précision
c'est un peu aussi le sens de votre
question j'imagine c'était de dire
comment est ce que un bail des nez se
sent personnellement touché oui le fait
de perdre il a perdu sa fille certes pas
dans un match où thing mais dans un
accident de voiture et son fils beau
physicien c'est un bébé voilà mais
perdre deux ans on a senti cette nuit
c'était aussi et c'est très américaine
ce père de famille qui dit quand il dit
je suis fatigué tout cela on sent une
forme de lassitude à la fois personnel
politique est une forme d'impuissance
parce que c'est cela aussi qui
l'expriment derrière le je suis fatigué
je suis fatigué un peu comme s'il n'y
avait pas d'issue où il n'en voyait pas
donc il ya aussi eu un appel aux
républicains
il ya une forme de oui à cette volonté
d'aller au delà du camp c'est une façon
de dire essayons d'aller au delà de nos
camps respectifs
oui mais sabrina van tassel tous les
démocrates on l'a dit ils sont pas anti
armes c'est pas aussi binaire que ça
vous imaginez vous en avez rencontré
beaucoup qui répète son croire moi moi
moi j'ai passé des journées entières
avec des parents qui ont perdu leurs
enfants et qui son tour le prg aux armes
et qui finissent quand même par me dire
fausse page et tout le monde a le droit
de se protéger
d'accord et tout le monde a le droit de
riposter tout le monde alors en fait on
a un peu l'impression que c'est que
c'est quand même c'est que c'est grave
et c'est grave et en ça fait tellement
partie de la culture et des lions au
planning n'est toi tu as ta culture nous
on a notre culture franco américaine
américaine mais bon tu vas fort je
reçois poids de secours du de ce point
de vue le pape s'exprime en heure la
religion quand même très grande place
aux etats-unis est-ce que les églises
participe à ce débat ou pas du tout
qu'elle soit protestants ou catholiques
les allemands alors lisez les églises et
suivent un peu c'est voir les
évangélistes an plus tôt contre est
conservateur aux états unis ils sont
plutôt favorable au port d'armes ils
vont pas critiquer évidemment ce que la
majorité de leurs de l'heure soit y
pense donc c'est vrai que les églises
saison elles ont un rôle parce qu'elles
ont tissé ce pays elles ont tissé les
racines de ce pays et mai et puis à la
confiance individuelle dont vous parliez
c'est à dire qu'on a on a confiance en
l'individu c'est un pays qui a confiance
dans l'individu et qui se dit
effectivement si on est tous armés on
est suffisamment de gentil pour arrêter
les méchants en gros c'est ça c'est
parce que le message de la nra passe on
dit c'est une industrie mais ils ont
quand même y met l'accent sur des ddd
marqueur très très important pour
l'identité de tous les américains et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut oublier et
l'interdiction globale et c'est pour ça
l'intelligence d'obama quand il a dit je
ne vous donne pas en comparaison à la
france où je ne sais quel pays d'europe
je voudrais en comparaison l'australie
qui est un pays qui sur le plan des
valeurs de la tradition anglo saxonne du
goût de la chasse du rapport à la nature
de pu être comparées à notre pays les
états unis à notre mode de vie et ils
ont réussi à éradiquer ce fléau parce
qu'ils se sont dit trop c'est trop que
l'histoire existe mais que le présent et
le futur existe aussi et qu'il faut
protéger nos enfants et en mettant le
doigt et d'ailleurs joe biden qui fait
très souvent de l'eau baba il y avait
aussi du joe biden dans l'aube à bas
d'hier il ya du de l'obama dans le bail
d'aujourd'hui eh bien il a repris
exactement ces mots il reprend
exactement ces mots et il dit
effectivement on a une exceptionnalité
négative c'est très important de
l'exceptionnalité aux etats unis nous
sommes les états unis d'amérique on a
une mission on a quelque chose de tout à
fait il ya quelque chose de bestial hic
mais là c'est une exceptionnalité
négative parce qu aucun pays du monde ne
voit mourir ses enfants de cette
manière-là aucun je voudrais qu'on ouvre
un chapitre sur le lobby des armes ou
l'avait déjà évoqué jean-claude beaujour
ce il est puissant quelques chiffres
fondée en 1871 devient officiellement à
l'oubli en 75 c 5 millions de membres et
un budget annuel de 300 millions de
dollars jean-claude beaujour et la lra
at elle vraiment le pouvoir de faire et
défaire certaines carrières politiques
non seulement la réponse est oui oui
très clairement puisque aux états unis
un acteur privé
entreprise peut financer sans grandes
limites alors que chez nous vous ne
pouvez pas donner plus de les
entreprises privées n'ont pas le droit
de financer une campagne politique et à
titre personnel vous finirez par delà de
4700 euros voilà donc les choses sont
claires et sa limite quand même le coût
des campagnes n'est pas le même donc le
coût de sièges de députés français n'a
rien à voir avec un siège de sénateur de
représentants de représentants qu on
voit bien que la chasse au financement
est importante aux etats unis c'est le
premier point et puis il y à un deuxième
point pour qu'on comprenne bien la force
quand on 10,5 millions 1,5 million
d'adhérents si on rapporte ça au cas
français c'est comme si vous aviez une
association qui avait qui avait un
million d'adhérents quand vous avez une
asso sans france 15 millions d'années
quand ça commence à peser vous parlez du
budget un budget cinq fois moins
important ça vous fait a vu environ 60
millions imaginer une association qui
aurait 60 millions d'euros de budget
vous imaginez un peu ce qu'elle peut
faire et puis ils sont réelles et très
inconduite à washington dans les cercles
de pouvoir évidemment quand au lime et
très introduite au niveau des états donc
c'est vrai qu'ils ont une réactivité un
militantisme qui est important un
dernier point parce qu'on a beaucoup
parlé des armes moi je pense qu' il ne
faut pas non plus minorer la manière
dont seront utilisés ces armes et le
fait que la fracture sociale de la
société américaine le trafic de drogue
le la pauvreté ici ou là favorise malgré
tout tout ce qui est utile isation
d'armes à feu et c'est donc peut-être
aussi qu'à côté à 6 à 80% la question du
transport de l'utilisation des armes est
importante je pense que l'eau n'était
gens dire intellectuelle voudrait qu'on
dise qu'au moins 20% il faut aussi que
la mairie travaille sur cette fracture
sociale cette fracture économique cette
disparité de quartier un autre on est
dans un quartier plus ou moins riches on
est dans un quartier plus ou moins
pauvres et les risques ne sont pas les
mêmes c'est vrai que certains ont pu
dire ah mais vous savez l'histoire
d'armes à feu c'est aussi beaucoup ces
questions de drogués solide ou des
règlements de comptes entre drogué ce
qui est ce qui existe aussi mais
justement si on veut lutter contre ça
quelle politique sociale
sabrina c'est
la communication je reste sur le lobby
nra comment ils communiquaient ce que ça
veut dire quoi c'est d'éclipsé des
publicités c'est sais quel type d'action
pour continuer de d'infuser on va dire
dans dans l'opinion et la culture
américaine grey énorme qui dure
parfois après près d'une semaine où on
vient en famille et où on a les vraies
valeurs américaines voilà on croit en
dieu on à son arme on est souvent blancs
quand même voilà et donc c'est des
valeurs qui sont qu'ils sont quand même
cher aux américains bon là elle
récemment la hénin a peu eu des
problèmes on a ils ont les démocrates on
va dire on va essayer justement de les
attaquer sur la manière dont il gérait
en fait l'organisation ils ont été un
peu me lis un peu mise à mal mais en
fait peu importe ils s'en sortent
toujours on a l'impression en fait c'est
quand même assez assez incroyable quoi
c'est vraiment quelque chose auquel
quelque chose que l'on peut pas toucher
aussi du matériel pédagogique c'est très
important de dire qu'ils ont aussi une
communication à l'égard des plus jeunes
des écoles qu'ils transmettent beaucoup
de matériel pédagogique gratuit que
certaines écoles accueillent avec
beaucoup de voilà peut-être de légèreté
parce que dès l'origine la nra n'a pas
eu comme objectif que de défendre le
port d'armes et la possession d'armes
ils ont eu dès l'origine l'objectif de
former les citoyens américains à l'
usage de ces armes donc ils se disent
dans une mission pédagogique même ils
vont dire par rapport à cela vous voyez
il faudrait effectivement que tout la
faute toute la population américaine qui
est un grand peuple une grande nation
libre effectivement est tout à fait
conscient des enjeux soient formés au
port d'armes puisse voir comment
l'utiliser et c'est pour ça que les
syndicats enseignants bien sûr mais
c'est pas évident mais je suis en train
de défendre mais c'est pour ça que les
syndicats d'enseignants répondent à la
nra notamment en floride quand on leur
dit vous allez devoir être aussi des
tireurs d'élite nous ne pouvons pas être
des enseignants et être formé par la lra
à réagir 1 h 15 un homme avec un ar 15
qui rentre dans notre classe alors il ya
aussi toutes les associations les
familles de victimes des tueries tueries
de masse ou tueries dont on parlait
c'est à dire quotidienne et qui font
elles pas du tout la une des journaux
des parents qui se mobilisent 10 qui se
regroupent en associations là quelques
images de votre documentaire et on va
voir un extrait le témoignage d'une
grand mère dont la fille a été tuée
laissant deux enfants derrière elle on
écoute
cristal 56 ans élève ses petits enfants
depuis la mort brutale de sa fille
comme elle de nombreux grands pas ont
remplacé les parents à la sortie des
écoles
c'est une conséquence directe de la
guerre des arbres
quel âge avait t-il quand vous avez dû
vous en occuper
il avait fêté ses cinquante
soit 0,8 avec 23 mois
ci c'est mon bébé
c'est dur d'accepter qu'elle appelle
maman b au lieu de l'entendre mathema me
connaît les autres petits
c'est un peu notre tableau de famille
fait là c'est la dernière photo qu'on a
fait tous ensemble en fait c'était pour
mes 50 ans
immortalisée sans savoir que c'était le
dernier on serait tous réunis
quatre enfants biologiques
savoir si j'avais perdu deux
voilà extrait de votre du commentaire
les armes delà de la colère et est ce
qu'il ya parce que là bon elle est
membre d'une association
avec d'autres parents ou grands-parents
autres ça qui ont perdu leurs enfants
est-ce que ce que c'est un lobby est ce
qu'il peut peser puisqu'on est en train
de parler du poids des lobbys alors et
fait partie de l'organisation qui
s'appelle membres demands actionnaires
demandent justement des actions quoi les
actes et
non même si ça pèse un nombre incroyable
de personnes elles sont devenues de plus
en plus
importante un petit peu partout aux
états unis parce que c'est dans tous les
états confondues donc oui elles ont
elles ont quand même elles ont elles ont
leur mot à dire elle s'exprime elle
essaie justement de faire en sorte que
et bien au congrès les bonnes personnes
soit élu pour justement limiter l'accès
aux armes mais malgré tout on va dire il
ya un petit peu une lassitude quoi parce
que malgré tout ce qu'elles peuvent
faire
les lois sont telles que voilà on n'a
pas éradiqué je ne sais pas combien de
millions d'armes aux états unis
voilà dix et la stalle turner à la
chanson son beau fils a pris à acheter
une arme comme ça et il a décidé un jour
de tuer toute sa famille et c'est un
mâle était légal et il n'avait jamais
touché une arme avant dernier mot juste
des animaux mais c'est vrai que ce sont
pas les mêmes rapports de pouvoir
lorsqu'on voit la force de frappe de nra
mais même avec des militants volontaires
etc vous savez bien le poids de la
communication le poids des documents etc
etc quand vous avez 300 millions entre
300 et 400 millions de dollars de budget
ça vous laisse faire autre chose que du
militantisme de base même s'il très il
était impressionnant ce militantisme de
base 0 voilà merci encore merci à tous
les trois d'avoir participé à ce débat
votre documentaire les armes de la
colère est donc disponible sur my canal